[Music]
How is Cristian Cásseres greeting you with
his brief snow report in Spanish?
Kobe 19 cases continue to drop
here in southern Nevada, but
we are still on the list of states
that require the mandatory use of
masks by health authorities  locals
say everyone should follow
safety protocols to prevent the
spread of the virus this includes
wearing a mask washing
hands frequently and getting
screened when necessary they
also remind the community that
vaccinations can prevent
hospitalizations  and to death
and if you are preparing to travel from
henry reeve international airport today
or tomorrow you better check your
flight status thousands of flights are being
canceled due to winter storms on
wednesday afternoon over 40 flights
were canceled here many of  these
belonged to southwest
zwanziger airlines and experienced the effort that
station  casino prepares for its new
resort in the southeast of the valley
workers are already laying the concrete for
what will be the range station however
it is not expected to open its doors
until next year the company is also
putting
end and sky spawn inspired sheet that  damage northeast for
possible expansion in the meantime text
station and party in general remain
closed and cold
temperatures continue here in the valley we will have
some breezes but sunny skies
for today these winds will
make it feel a little colder than usual
Normally the temperatures will reach
50 degrees in the afternoon but the temperatures will rise
and we will return to 70
degrees for next week I am
Cristian Cásseres with your brief
Spanish ignition news good day
[Music]